Welcome back to Sims 4
We’re going to play a game
And we're going to.. um..
Have some..
..Fun?...
Okay, so what so what I want to do
is..
I want to- um
I want to-
I want to experiment with- uh-
A type of playing this game that I've never really played before.
First of all, we're not making the Ipliers
We already did that.
What kind of-
What kinda-
What kind of crazy person do you think I am?
That I'm just going to be remaking the Ipliers.
No, that's stupid. You're stupid.
((I'm not stupid))
I'm gonna be making some original characters
Because everyone is always clamoring,
Like-
"DUH, DO DARKIPLIER."
DO- DO- THE- THE-
GOOGLE
No. It's stupid, you're stupid
and I'm not stupid (ok, mark)
Any suggestions will get you an instant ban. (Oh no...)
(silence)
Maybe? ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Maybe. ( ͡o ͜ʖ ͡o)
So everybody SHUT UP, and let me deal with this
We're gonna call you- ( ͡° ᴥ ͡°)
-sigh- ( ͡° ͜ ͡°)
We're gonna call you Shphingo ヽ(͡◕ ͜ʖ ͡◕)ﾉ
We're gonna(͡• ͜໒ ͡• )
ff -laughs- (° ͜ʖ°)
We're gonna call you Shphingoヽ(͡◕ ͜ʖ ͡◕)ﾉ
Is that? Sh- no. ( ͡◉ ͜ʖ ͡◉)
Sphingo
Shphingo
SH-PA-HINGO
Alright.
What do we got here..ff -laughs-
Oops
Okay.
Alright. Whoops
Uh-
oops
Can I make the arms longer. -WHOOSH-
WOAH- hu- hu
Uh- hu- hu
Can I make the arms longer in any way?
Is that even remotely possible about this
Sim: Ah!
Uh huh..
Tell me about it.
Can I make your shoulders sh-
-mini stroke- Woah.
Alright.
That's good there.
uh- huh.
I don't like it.
I don't love it actually.
I don't like it at all.
How do I do the face again?
I've completely forgotten how to do anything in this game.
I've got all this hair bullshit here.
Oh. That- that's not what the picture looked like!
Uh- that's good enough
I call this the- uh
'May I please speak to your manager" look.
Detail edit mode.
That's what I was looking for!
Okay, this gone.
These sultry.
This curious, but only one of them.
Can only one of them be curious?
Okay. Very surprised.
Flared.
Pinched.
Drooped.
Uh- smooched.
Uh- unplumped.
Very plumped
-laughs- Bottom lip!
Uhhh
Chin: Chiseled but lumpy
There we go.
Ears,
Real- Uhhhh
Nothing, -laughs- apparently.
You can't edit ears.
Ears are the forbidden zone.
As is -laughing- obvious to everybody.
Ears are absolutely forbidden.
Okay, how about..
Mouth:
Back
That's good.
Face: foward.
Chin: out
Gullet:
Up
Oh, no
-Laughing-
There we go
Why- There we go!
F- That's what I'm taking about
Alright, Nose: Uh Whoop
Yeap- No
Let's not be comical about this.
That's good there.
Bridge: Up.
-Maniacally Laughs-
Let's j- try to take this a little bit seriously.
Eyes: Sunken
Alright
Looks good from the front.
Oh, yeah! From the front, pretty good.
From the side. (a party)
Hmm.. not-
Not as-
Not as good.
Shphingo here- uh
Shphingo here-
Oof
There is no way to edit the ears.
Okay, it's- it's a God-damn mystery
Your ears are an enigma and they don't work half the time, that's fine.
Basically your entire face is trying to escape your skull.
-mess of words-
-Chuckle-
I think I see- uh
A problem
Ohhhh
- whispers- Even better.
Even better.
Okay, you know what? I'm gonna get out of here.
And I'm going to see what a different hair style looks like.
oh!
Ohh...
-Laughing-
Grunhilda!
Alright, so this is Shphingo,
uh-
Brunhilda. -laughs-
Let's see what else we can do to ruin this.
ugh, no
ugh
No!
no.
Shhiit
GOD
FU
CKING DAMMIT
Back.
Okay, perfect.
Alright it's fine. Everything is fine.
Everything is still-
Here we go.
Alright.
This is Shphingo Brunhilda.
We call her Shpinny
'Cause, WHOOO
-Laughs- She loves to shpin.
Oh, God with the shoulders.
Alright.
Straunk
Un-straunk.
Broad- shouldered
But un-straunk
Rotund
non-rotund
oh no. -laugh-
Neck: Thicc
As always. Need to hold up that head somehow.
Can we get a little bit of spina-b Woah!
Ah!
Alright.
Hunch
That's good...
What about the lower lumbar
Mmmmm
Nope
hmm
nope
Hmm
NopE
Tucus:
Out there
Alright
KnEEs:
Knobbly
Ah shit
You can't do the knees
I was tryna make ya...
hideously deformed,
But somehow I'm
even more attracted to you.
You're a God-damn delight
Now lets see all these
God-damn outfits that I paid money for-
Perfect!
Alright
Nothing else-
euh-
Perfect
That's your
*chuckles*
Day-to-day
Out-fit.
*laughs*
Hmmmm
What did i pay money for?
Perfect
I love it.
Boots:
Already perfect but let's see if we can improve on perfect-
better-
Even better
Got it
Oh
Oh no
I don't like that I can see your spinal column so much tho
Ehh
At least shes happy
Ok...
Alright
Well this is SHPHINGO BRUNHILDA.
Shreally?
Really?
Wh-
*Laugh*
Devi-
*Laugh again...*
-ance
Animal?
Anim-
Whaaaa?
She wants to be a furry?
Is that what that is?
Is what that is supposed to be?
Is- Is this supposed to be-
Oh. Just a friend of the animals.
Okay.
Not- Defifinitely not a Furry, but-
Ya know..
-whispers- Maybe.
maybe
You never know
Could be
No-
Not saying its a furry but- it could be
you are..
God-damn self confident.
-laughs-
No, stop that. You know..
y- uh Brunhilda please stop that.
Actually
Imna rename this as-
the first name is gonna be Brunhilda
'Cuz that's obviously a First name.
And this is gonna be D-Shphingo
The Shhhphingo Family.
Br-
Very Cheerful
Happy as-
Ggugh
-Sim talking nonsense-
-Menacing music-
Alright
So.. Very happy
Very-
Very happy.
Squeamish
Why are you still smiling? -Laughs-
She can't not smile.
Clumsy
-laughing- It's cuz she's so top heavy that she literally can not keep balanced.
-Inhale-
Her tiny waste is never gonna be able to keep track.
A Goofb-
-sim talks-
-Sharp inhale from mark- (Calmeth young one)
-Exhale-
Okay. She's self assured,
Ah!
Cheerful goofball
Alright, so this is Brunhilda.
[ laughing ]
Play with genetics?
Ugh!
Add a cult Sim? What is a cult Sim?
Huh? Alien? Tha- alien!
oh.
Imma go back to Brunhilda for a second here 'cause I didn't get the voice...
Brunhilda: Kampoosa, haha!
Brunhilda: Antrep Kalefoye
[ laughs ]
Alright, what walk style?
[ laughs ] Jesus.
Oh my God!
Alright... yeah okay, we're done. Alright, this is Schpengo.
This one's-
This- Ah-
We'll figure out the name-
The name comes later when you get to a person that-
whoa
*amazed noise*
*laughing* Can this sim use the toilet standing?
oh
That's- That's fascinating!
"Custom Gender Settings!"
Oh
How forward thinking!
I'm not gonna mess with that
but
How forward thinking of you
*weird walking noise*
*mark giggling*
Ya god damn snooty
alright
Shpingo
okay
I like what we've got goin-
nope
Thats-
Hang on
We- we've gotta really
alright
First off:
Let's get some things right.
Right off the bat-
n-okay
That's- that's just the FIRST step.
Alright let's fix you
You are just so
oKAY
You are just-
okay
You-
*iNHALE*
oh woah K woah woah woah what the fucking fuck
Why are you in our home?!
Wieh
Can you..
Try to cheer up?
There's no
Are you just part of this family now?
Oh
Kay
Alright, there's no option to get her to leave.
So you're here.
Anvi Gupta?
wait a minute (in a low voice)
wait
GASP
She doesn't have a reflection! IT'S A VAMPIRE!
She's ju.... she's got no rEfLeCtIoN
She's got no reflection.
(longer gasp)
she's a vampire
How do we get you, to get out out of here?
Well, uncomfortable, okay, horrible shower. You know what whatever.
We're just gonna go to sleep and if you leave, that's great.
(low voice) Yes, thank you for getting off the bed.
(watches intently)
(surprised look)
(She's a wizard harry)
(Quietly) Oooookkaaaayyy.
Okay.
That was weird
Alright, we're just not gonna talk about that
No one mention that
Nothing happened
iT's cHrIStmas!
WhaHoo!
Father Winter, please! Daddy Winter, come give us presents!
Ppllllleeeeaaassseeee.
Come on, Daddy Clause. (little bitch giggling)
-Mark's mouth farts-
Daddy Winter, please! Daddy! Oh, God.
Daddy Winter, please! Come down my chimney! (more giggling)
Ugh.
I'm so sorry for the way that I am. I'm-I'm sorry.
Look- listen. Listen. I'm sorry.
I am sorry. I'm not sorry at all.
Were you just crying?! Were you crying under the-
Were you crying? I don't know what we're doin here.
I've- I've forgotten the point of life.
Give birth in... Idunno.
Alright, come on, let's see it. (claps hands) Chop chop.
Come on, we got a schedule to keep, let's go!
Any minute now, any min-any minute now, you're gonna pop like a water balloon.
Good thing we got our baby basement all set up and ready to go.
Here we go, any minute now, this baby's gonna (claps hands) boom! zang! zoom! Whoooo right outta there.
Come on...(Markimoo getting impatient) Come on!
We're never gonna see this baby. We're never gonna see this *burp* baby!
Whoa-whoa, whoa, whoooaaa.
What- Daddy- Daddy Winter?
"Clement Frost"...
(Ho Ho Ho!)
ooooookay...
Just right on the ground there, eh?
Okay, alright, well...
Y'just gonna..
just gonna be here?
You a vampire too?
I can't get his reflection from here
Okay, he's not a vampire, we got that for sure!
Can I help you sir?
Can I help...
...Yooouuu sir?
Another glass of water!
Ooh, another glass of water, he's gotta rehydrate.
For all his...festive needs
Who are you?
Oh, *laughs*
He came out of nowhwere!
*giggling* I'm just gonna drink water and set the glasses down everywhere
Is that what we're gonna do, Mr. Frawst? *giggling*
Get a door?
No!!
OOH
Uh oh!
Well
Ummmmmm
Not-
*giggling* Father Clause
*high pitched mark* Did you just pick up the glass on the f-
*still high pitched* What are you doing??
thank you?
thank you so much?
i apreciate it?
Oh, you cock ass!
*sim laughs maniacally*
*sim starts singing randomly*
and you're done.
oh
okay
alright
Please, Mr. Frost
Don't steal Mope-O's wife.
I dunno where this is leading or how this got to this situation at all...
but anyway- and you're just making... garlic bread.
Okay
Alright
Well, *indistinct mumbling* I-I think this-
this lifestyle has just gone... awry
In many ways
and I feel... *long sigh*
*si*-OOH
Wow
Um...
I'm just gonna see where time leads us
Oh... cock.
If you die from this fire before you get to...
witness the miracle birth of you wife(??) and your first baby- okay, good.
Alright.
That's time for Santa Claus to peace out there.
Arright
*Santa Claus voice*
Um, bye bitches. I'm out, I'm off tuh...
I've spent a few hours here, drank your water, and I'm off.
*normal voice*
Why is my mailbox over there?
Check for Winter Fest gifts?
I got three candels
...
Okay.
Can you have this baby, please?
Just have baby!
Have the baby, we need to fill up the cribs!
We spent all our money on cribs.
Oh, we have money?!
How did we get money?!
How did we get money...?
Okay, well, uh...
We'll buy a toilette.
No, you know what...
let's not
Oooh, boy. I have no idea-
WhOA, Brunilda is bursting!
She's bursting!
To have baby... heeeeeee- have baby.
(Owwww)
WHHHHHHHHERE ARE YOU GOING?
*Indistinct grunting from Sim*
(If listening, please close your eyes for this part)
*Earrape*
Errybody say "Hi" to little Grundle.
Hiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAH
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAh
WHAAOH, my god!
Alright
Time for baby nuvver- nuv- number two!
*Wheezing*
It's an option...
oh, no!
Ohhhh nooooo!
Awhhhhh nohohohohohohohoho!
Oh no!
*Concerning laughter*
ohhh no...
Ugh, it's gonna be a bush baby!
Oh god, it's gonna be a bush baby...
oh it's a bush...
baby
Oh geez, for the love of god.
Ohwr(?)
Excelent b-good bush baby
Oh my god.
There we go. No-no one saw,
no one wanted to see.
Everyone knew, but...
ya know, no one wanted to see.
Try again, c'mon, you gotta get it in the...
Uh-oh
They're goin' for the baby.
Alright, there, here they-
Oh, baby doesn't get fed.
Alright, here we go.
Back in the bush!
Okay, round two! Just in case, you know.
Just to really solidify it.
Alright, let's buy a... terlet.
Alllriiight, okay,  The Ambassador.
Emphasis on 'assador'.
You need to take a pregnancy tes-
FIFTEEN DOLLARS?
*saliva noises*
Fifteen feuck-duckin' dollars?
Awwww
You get f-home, already? We need to know.
If we're gonna need to go in the bush again.
*western accent*
Hawney, we gotta go in the bush again!
Turned up negative.
I know, I tried real hard last time...
but you know how these things is.
They figure- oh it worked!
Nevermind, we don' gotta go-
Whuhuhuhuhuhu?
I got some good news.
Anudder one.
Ooby, ooby!
*mouse squeak*
heh heh heh heh
Yahooo!
Oh, boy. A baby factory.
That's what we are.
Oh, boy. Okay.
And we're gonna die very soon...
Very soon.
Brunhilda, you're- why are you twelve daysfrom age up?
Are you ageless because you're a mother?
Is that what it is? Why are you say- taking so long to be-
well, uh, Mope-O, he's-
he's gettin' older by the second!
Why have you not aged at all?
*reading*
Sims that are pregnant cannot age up...
*gasp*
So if she's always pregnant...
she never grows old...
Why didn't every- ah- wh- does everyone know about this secret?
If you're PREGNANT
You can't get OLD
Oh my GOD, I gotta get PREGNANT!
Oh, okay! It's as eas-easy as that!
WOW!
You wanna WooHoo in a boosh.
That's an aspiration of yours.
Yeah, okay. One last WooHoo...
Nope. Can't do it. She's asleep.
Can't do it.
Hey, wake up.
Wake up!
Hey, wake up! We gotta WooHoo.
We gotta do this, we have to!
We have to!
Arright, here we go. This is my dream.
Ah, what a supportive marriage.
Man,
One thing you gotta say, they are truly in love.
It takes love to be willing to...
*inhale*
go through all of that.
Especially for a horrible, hideous alien.
And Grundle, Grundle Shphingo,
you are...
oh my god, you are being horribly abused.
Okay, one of you should probably change the baby!
Alright, we're... we're just gonna ignore the- the...
Okay, anyway, that's...
I think...
I think it's...
Alright
I'm gonna go away now.